[Music]
first game against ray robson this is
round one
yeah i got a pretty
pretty unfortunate
um pretty unfortunate colors this
tournament so i had six blacks and five
whites
and i had black against all of the top
seed so i had black against dominguez
wesley
um caruana
shankland and robson you know which is
not particularly desirable um all of the
guys who are known to be
super theoretical i have black against
but it is what it is
it's based on a drawing of lots so
everybody draws a number from one to
twelve
and basically the first half has six
whites and five blacks and then the
second half the the the
the bigger the number the worse
um the worse your your seating is
basically because the more blacks you
have that's just the way it works um i
drew number 11.
so
not great
yeah i mean starting with rey with black
is
a very very difficult way to begin the
tournament
and as you guys all know i played the
alakine
uh
mostly because
i i wanted to throw everybody off guard
this tournament i knew that if i went
into people's prep
i probably wouldn't have much of a
chance
i probably wouldn't have much of a
chance
um
and
mostly the strategy worked this
tournament i mean it worked against
dominguez it worked against wesley
but here i
i um
i took i took too much of a risk the
alakan is just not feasible i think
against uh modern gm's who know what to
do
and i think ray demonstrated
really not the refutation but
the line that comes as close
as as a line can come to the refutation
just the four pawns attack
so
e5 knight d5
d4 d6
and here honestly i was really hoping
that rey would go knight f3 which is the
most popular move this is the modern
main line
and white is supposed to be better here
as well but after d595
the the sort of modern move is c6
and i analyzed this and i felt like rey
in his online games was not too
confident in these positions
and i thought i would have a pretty good
chance to equalize it's also very solid
and positional ray is a very tactical
player so i thought i would try to take
the game into a more quiet direction
but to my chagrin and i knew that this
might happen ray goes four pawns attack
c4 f4
and
the first
11 moves of the game are
the main line of the four pawns attack
i've done a speed run game on this so
you could check out my video i go in
more depth
on the actual theory of the four pawns
attack
but so here i'm just gonna go pretty
quickly through the opening takes takes
knight c6
so the point is of course the plaque
tries to
attack white center and white tries to
support it bishop b3 is is very
important not knight f3
because of the very unpleasant bishop g4
creating a nasty pin against the knight
so bishop e3
basically white waits for me to develop
my bishop
my light squared bishop and only then
he goes knight f3
um and the thing is as i indicated in
the speed run bishop g4 even here is a
move it's it's a it's a legitimate line
but it's it's not very good the loss of
a tempo is too much to sacrifice here
and i think
simply queen d2 is supposed to be good
for white
i can sort of ruin white structure a
little bit but it's
it's not enough to warrant losing a temp
also this pawn gets to f4
this is really bad so i i went for the
main line which is just bishop e7
and by the way i think a lot of people
have a tendency to develop the bishop
here
but as i've indicated many times when
you're evaluating whether a pin is
dangerous
there's two things to consider the first
is whether the pinned piece is defended
by a pawn
if it is it's very hard to put pressure
on the snipe the second thing is how
permanent or temporary the pin is and
here the pin is very temporary because
if white simply develops his bishop then
he is going to castle out of the pin and
the bishop is going to be left
you know
a bishop is going to be left um
you know
it's like miners who
come to california for the gold rush two
years late it's like all of the gold has
been panned already
um
you're gonna look awkward here
all right so bishop e7 bishop b2
high and dry that's a good expression
castles castles
and
f6 which is still considered the main
line
chipping into white center getting rid
of the c5 pawn obviously that comes at a
cost and the cost that it comes at is
that the e6 pawn is now a pretty
significant weakness
but uh but at least optically black's
pieces look very nice
all of black's minor pieces seem to be
doing something okay so queen d2 still
still theory
uh connecting the rooks and queen e7
this is basically
what's known as the tabia right this is
the moment at which
white's got a couple of different ways
to deviate
uh sorry on the next move so rook ad one
rook ad this is still my prep this is
there's still hundreds of games in this
position
and the most popular move in this
position
is basically to say all right black has
this pin going and it's to move the
queen back to c1
and here i had uncovered a really sexy
sequence of moves which actually
equalizes for black so this is really
cool because most people don't actually
know this they play queen c1
what is this sequence well black starts
with e5
this does not look like a good move
because of d5
but now
black has
a really really cool sequence that
exploits
uh this awkward placement of the queen
on two does anybody know
how black should continue or you can
kind of intuitively sense what the next
move is it is
very intuitive to play the next move
but what's not intuitive is sort of the
follow-up to the next move
so you might be thinking well you don't
want to go back to b8 that looks really
bad
um
attempting move is to play pawn e4 but
this is the mapwa the most popular wrong
answer and i think the reason this is
bad is because
for instance white can simply go back to
e1
and as you'll see there are two pieces
hanging and no good way to defend them
knight before is one of those moves that
also looks i guess it looks tempting
because you're trying to get to c2 but
not good enough because
i mean again even even 91 here
attacking the bishop and covering the c2
square followed by a3 you're going to
chase this knight away to a6 you don't
want
you don't want the knight to be exiled
to siberia
yeah the move is knight d4 actually
so this is upon sacrifice as you as you
can see knight takes d4 e takes d4
bishop takes d4 and here the crucial
move
here the crucial move it looks like
there's no compensation the bishop is
defended but all of a sudden it turns
out that this queen on c1 is actually
very poorly placed
and this next move
is really hard to deal with yeah bishop
g5
all of a sudden yeah the queen has to go
to a1 which is not never a good sign
now the initiative continues you play
the move c5
hitting the bishop on d4
and there's a lot of tactics here the
point is if i take san passan there's a
very simple sequence or it takes e3
bishop e3 check and we win a piece
that's pretty easy so the bishop has to
drop back to f2 now we go bishop c2
we hit the rook
the rook has only one feasible square e1
and now rook takes f2
rook takes f2 bishop e3 and this is
supposed to be equal uh there's a couple
of correspondence games that went this
way but black has an initiative and
enough compensation for the pawn big
attack against the king a pin
everything is breathing
objectively it's equal but white has to
be very careful here
so there's still a couple games in this
line which is which is pretty
interesting so i was really hoping that
ray wouldn't know this
because it's not a commonly known line
um it's not a commonly known outline but
uh ray took about
seven to ten minutes here he i think he
he told me after the game that he did
actually know this line or he didn't
remember it but he sort of reconstructed
it
and he plays the best move which is just
king h1
this is the kind of move that takes the
air out of the building completely
very classy move it completely
removes any ideas connected with this
diagonal like now i will never have any
kind of combination associated with like
a check on e3 or a pin
and
the reason i think people don't play
this move normally is because they're
afraid of the spin but this is
the nature of chess at this level is you
got to be incredibly concrete everything
has to be considered
uh concretely you can't use general
principles like oh
there's a pin i'm scared of this so i'm
going to move my queen away
you can't do that
black has some attempts here like knight
takes d4 but they don't work
for instance um
let me try to remember why exactly this
move doesn't work
i'm going to try to avoid using the
engine when possible but sometimes i'm
going to confirm my conclusion to the
engine
yeah so actually bishop takes d4 or
knight takes d4 are both good
i think knight takes d4 is the reason i
didn't do this
bishop takes d4 bishop takes d4 c5
it looks like
you're winning the bishop back but white
has the very powerful bishop takes e5
and you're hitting the queen you have to
take and now it takes the rook
boom boom boom boom and already white is
better but now in comes g4 the bishop is
lost as well so this is just really bad
maybe maybe g4 is not the most accurate
but
either way
this doesn't work out okay so i decided
to make
uh
an improving move of my own h6 which is
still the best move i think just uh you
know taking some squares under control
and ray reciprocates with h3 also you
know same kind of idea we're both making
some lift and improving our position
this is about where
my preparation ended i i knew that this
that this line existed
i checked it briefly before the game but
i didn't really remember what i had
looked at here for black
so i took some time here
and i figured that my only real way
to get this to work is to somehow put
some pressure on the d4 pawn
i thought that
if i don't find a way to pressure the
spawn black does not have a clear plan
that's actually the problem with this
position because it's so hard to
pressure this pawn it's so well defended
black simply does not have a good way to
improve the position whereas white has
a million ways that he can make small
improvements and push me off the board
and this position is practically
speaking really really bad for black
objectively it's about point five
thank you md knight i think to michigan
so this is where i kind of started
regretting my opening choice
um
okay
so i played rook d7
i think very natural move either
preparing to double or preparing to
bring the queen back to d8
uh but the computer evaluation doesn't
really matter here it's more that it's
very very unpleasant and only now does
ray play queen c1 he's made all these
improving moves now he plays queen c1
and at this point already the movie 5 is
no longer applicable because now after
d5 knight t4
you can go down the same route
but
there's no
i mean the position has completely
changed there's no sacrifices the king
is safe
black is simply down upon right
so that doesn't work
uh black has to play more patiently so i
played rookie eight
um i seem to remember that this was one
of black's ideas
and basically the point here is that i
am preparing
i i'm trying to dissuade him from going
d5
on d5 is a pretty scary prospect so i'm
what i'm doing is i'm i'm doubling on a
closed file which is kind of a common
technique to stop the pawn breakthrough
because you're preparing for the
eventuality that the file opens and here
i take on d5 and i'm hitting the bishop
um i think this is a pretty good move i
don't think this is the big mistake so
rey
responds with the rook d2
so clearly that there's a lot going on
in the d file
i play queen back to d8
again trying to put more pressure on d4
and he doubles roxanne on d1
and yeah this is where i
you know i was continually feeling worse
and worse about my position now i
realize that there's no
clear continuation i've done basically
everything i can do and there's just no
there's no uh clear way to continue
i i briefly considered e5
um but after d5 knight d4
unfortunately
he doesn't play knight d4 in bishop d4
now there's bishop g5 with a pin
but what he does is he plays bishop to
xd4 and knight takes d4
and he hits my bishop on f5 so i don't
have time to play bishop g5
not good right
if i move my bishop back the knight gets
into e6
this is a
this is a complete disaster
so what is the approach in positions
where you don't know what to do well
generally you try to make small
improving moves you kind of start
playing the waiting game
and for two moves we play the waiting
game first i decided to flicking h8 get
my king out of the out of the kill zone
why couldn't you still play
g5 i mean that was never an idea
g5 is a little too crazy to weaken the
game like this
i think king h8 is fine
rey also plays the improving move b3
just um
well because the bishop on f5 was
hanging there
the bishop on f5 was hanging there so
b3 solidifying the pawn chain
and i've talked to my bishop back on h7
i also thought this was an improving
move because the bishop on f5 sometimes
is hanging
so in effect i'm trying to prepare e5
in some of these positions like now e5
is a potential idea
and rey
i think plays a really really powerful
move
um i actually think the computer was
indicating that somewhere around here
ray had a slightly better way to improve
his position but um
actually i think bishop h7 might be
inaccurate
i think bishop h7 might be inaccurate
the computer indicates that this was
really my only chance
to improve the position of the knight on
b6 because now this knight is staring at
the pawn
and is obviously my worst piece where
can this knight go well it can only
really go in one direction knight c896
but
the problem with going knight c8 is that
you are taking your eyes off of the d5
square so
the move d5 always needs to be
considered in response to knight c8
um e takes d5 knight takes d5 but
according to the computer this position
is actually not so bad for black you can
just continue with
you can continue with your plan and go
knight d6
very very scary to be under this kind of
pressure but on the other hand the
knights coming to e4
and there's a sense in which i think
black has gotten a lot of counter play
here
so
bishop h7 sort of missed the missed the
bus on that and after a long think ray
goes back to g1 bishop g1
um
yeah what is the idea i think the idea
is that after e5
now he can simply
play d takes e5
and because i moved my bishop away from
f5 it turns out that the rook on d7 is
not well defended enough
after knight takes c5 bishop takes b6
white wins a piece
white wins at peace well bishop g1 just
getting the bishop off of the e file i
think is the point
and black is losing a piece here
a takes b6 knight takes c5 the rook
hangs
after rook takes c2 oh he's even got
knight f7 here just winning the queen
pretty
straightforward idea
and here i lost my patience so black's
position is bad um it's just bad there's
no clear plan
and the way you know that is the engine
is indicating moves like a6 which
basically signals
there's no further way to improve the
position but it was not acceptable to me
and i
i got impatient here
and i decided
based on a fatal miscalculation to play
knight c8
and and to take this opportunity to
improve them to improve the knight
ray quickly goes d5 which i had
anticipated
e takes d5 knight takes d5 and this is
the critical position that i had spent
maybe 15 20 minutes evaluating
and
as often happens in games of this level
ultimately the game is decided by a
miscalculation right it's not really
a lack of understanding
you know partly it's the opening but
what really decides the game is a
miscalculation
so what did i miscalculate i thought
that i would play knight t6 here
i thought that i would play knight d6
now
white can win a piece here and i saw
that who can spot the way that white
wins a piece here
this is not what i missed
yeah very good
knight takes f6 queen takes f6 c5
but um that's not the end of the story
because i noticed that in playing h3 ray
had really weakened the g3 square
and i thought that i came up with a
really sneaky idea to go knight e4
give the rook and go knight g3 and
knight takes c2
okay so what's going on here the queen
is hanging
queen is hanging
and he has a very hard time finding a
good square for the queen
because
uh if he moves it anywhere then after
queen f4 black gets at the very least a
perpetual
so he has to move his queen while
keeping f4 under control there's two
ways to do that
the first is to go queen c4
but now the queen is clearly on a very
vulnerable spot and black has a really
really powerful response
that essentially forces a draw who sees
it
not knight a5 because then the queen can
swing to h4 for example it's actually
yeah rookie 4 is interesting
but the move is knight e5
knight e5 yeah and the tactical point is
that if he takes on e2 i have knight g4
check winning the queen
and what's even more important is that
this is not checkmate because i can
block with my bishop
and if he takes my knight well then this
is a draw queen takes e5 king h1 knight
g3 and it's a perpetual i don't think
black has more than that
so that's line number one now he's got
one other way to defend f4 and that is
play queen d2
and here i thought that i still play
knight e5 i thought that i still play an
id5 and i thought everything is great
i'm attacking the rook
he's still i mean it's the same the same
exact point i thought he has to take on
e5 and oh and then i win the queen and i
thought the black is a powerful attacker
but
i completely overlooked
uh the move rook d8 here
you can just move the rook
and i guess in my mind i had assumed
that after knight f3 gf i'm gonna have
something against his king
but the king is in fact completely safe
on h2 black can resign
you have one check on e5
and now the very simple f4 decides the
game this is a really strong move
and it's over black black's position
collapses i mean knight f4 rookie 8 and
queen takes f4 goodbye
and there's actually
actually wait no not queen take so far
what am i saying um
sorry
rook d8 boom boom boom boom boom
ray pointed this out after the game i i
didn't even notice this but he can't
take on f4 because of queenie two check
but the simple queen da decides forcing
the queen tree black is down in exchange
that's it
yeah so i missed i missed the mover of
d8 and obviously i was horrified when i
spotted this so i
i also looked around in this position i
spotted a move like bishop f5 here
but after rook takes c7 i
i didn't see
any kind of way to continue the attack
and i decided not to go maybe i should
have gone for this and played something
like bishop e4
the engine is indicating as an
interesting try
um if he takes then there's queen f4 and
i come back and take the rook but
the very powerful move queen d6
extinguishes the flames of black's
attack so
this just does not work
and
since 96 doesn't work that means i have
to keep my knight on ca and that means
the pressure on the d-file is going to
be completely overwhelming
and i didn't find any kind of way to put
up a resistance here i played the move
bishop e4
um the point is to try to force him to
move the knight away from d5 but after
knight takes f6
there's a further problem um rook takes
d2
he plays very strong move knight takes
d2
uh this is all based on a really really
beautiful tactical detail
the whole point of this is if you just
take the knight
and after 94 rookie four black is losing
here i mean there's too many weaknesses
white's got two bishops the knights are
terrible
the rook is coming to f1
it's just
it's there's no force to win but this is
absolutely miserable for black and in
the long run
there's no way that black's gonna be
able to keep the king safe
maybe this was objectively more
resilient but
it's so miserable i knew i was gonna
lose here so
so i suddenly spotted a second
idea that got me very excited for about
a second
what did i spot in this position and i
had already seen this when i took on d2
so
i spotted it i spotted it when he took
on f6
so obviously we know that loose pieces
drop off
always check for undefended pieces
there's an x-ray situation here
and there's another x-ray situation here
and so i took on g2
and this looks incredibly powerful king
takes g2 rook takes c2 check
and it looks like
black's all of a sudden attacking
but king f1
and what's going on here is that the
rook is hanging
and
currently white is up a piece if you
just move the rook then the knight's
going to move back and white is winning
but
um
the move queen d3 for a second
looked winning for black to me
this looks like he creates devastating
threats against the king and if he moves
this knight to hit the queen then i've
got queen f3 checkmate or i can cover
with my rook on d2
and this is where ray spotted an
incredible move it's not so difficult
when you get to this position to see it
because there's nothing else to do what
is the game-winning detail this didn't
happen
it's this is the the reason why i had to
veer off the path yeah queen b1
quiet but totally deadly because you
you know
you you go straight to the to the
linchpin
and no matter where the rook goes you
can give a double check but then he's
just gonna take the rook if you take the
knight and queen takes d3 there's a
classic x-ray protection here rook takes
d3 rook takes d3 white is up in exchange
and winning
that said there's no other there's no
squares for the queen you can't move the
queen and keep the rook protected
so unfortunately now the computer
indicated that maybe my last concrete
chance was was just to move the rook
and to basically say that white's king
is still experiencing some discomfort
and i still have some attacking chances
here white is winning it's plus three
plus four but rey would have had to be a
little bit more precise than in the game
but um
i decided
uh to go for a a different defensive
approach which turned out to be losing
essentially on the spot i took on d2
and then i took on f6 now again
optically it might look like black is
still okay because i've got a pawn for
the exchange and his king is a little
weak the issue is that these knights are
terrible my king is incredibly weak and
this bishop on g1 is not bad it's going
to go out to h2 very quickly and it's
going to hit the pawn on c7
so i i have to move my queen and keep fa
protected i have to go back to d8 first
he activates his queen now queen trades
are out of the question they lose on the
spot so queen ea
and now he brings the queen at f4
threatening queen f8 i have to
move my king
and unfortunately i have to give up one
pawn
okay i brought my queen out to e6 he
simply brings us back to g3 and now
queen juve where he played very
accurately all engine moves here queen
e7 and now in comes the bishop
now everything is breathing
um
and there's
there's no hope i go back to f7 and now
ray finds a very very classy
very very classy sequence queen ca check
king h7 now how does white end the game
immediately
this is like a super super classy move
because it simply does not give any
chances even though it's not necessarily
the top engine move
this is what i think some people don't
understand the engines don't always
advocate for the approach of trading
pieces
no rook f7 i just take
yeah queen c7
this force is a queen train
and
obviously this you can resign here
queen f5 is not does not end the game i
have king ga
so queen c7 i
i played queen e4 this is a last-ditch
attempt to organize some attack on the
king which believe it or not
you know helped me last a couple more
moves
because after queen h1 it's white has to
be accurate king e2 but the problem is
that if you give a check on d4 the king
just walks up to e3 there's no anchor
points there's no anchor points there's
too many pieces surrounding the king
there's no
no threats so he repeated wants to gain
time and make time control now king d2
the king easily escapes the check knight
e4
and now
you know i was hoping for
some phantom threats but he just goes
back to f4
queen c2 checking e3 fearlessly walking
into the center the center can be the
safest part of the board in these
situations that's another thing people
don't always understand but when you
when you're in the center you have the
most escape avenues
and uh
there's just no way to even give a
single check so knight back to e6
queen f5 one last trick that i found one
last trick if he takes on e6
i go queenie one check
and i i take the rook white is still
winning but
rey of course avoided that and played
bishop e5 getting the bishop in hitting
the queen
knight g5 check i knew that
you know this move loses on the spot but
i wanted to let him do something nice
queen takes
g5 and here i resigned because
if i give queenie one check it might
seem like a last glimmer of hope but the
queen comes back to e3 and white is up a
million things
so i resigned after queen takes g5 yeah
very nice finish and everything he did
in the end was like top engine moves he
gave me zero
not even an inkling of a chance or
counter play
so
yeah this is really really nice i mean
i i didn't feel like i played terribly
this game i felt like i made a series of
small inaccuracies leading up to one big
mistake
um
but at the same time ray just played a
you know vintage ray game he was just
incredibly precise
he knew the opening
um the losing move i think is knight c8
i think
the decisive mistake is 19 but black's
position is already really bad and i
think
according to my hasty post game analysis
playing knight c8 a move earlier
would have been
maybe
a serious chance to get some sort of
play because the difference is this
bishop on e3 is very vulnerable so now i
can go knight d6 and he cannot do the
same thing he did in the game that was
the point of bishop g1 it was a
brilliant prophylactic move
brilliant prophylactic move because
he understood that the whole point here
that when he plays d5
my rook comes alive so he neutralizes
the effect of rookie a
yeah so first game was a loss
but
not not the most painful loss i've ever
suffered by a long shot
and that got me to zero out of one the
second game
against jeffrey i managed to win and
that was
sort of my second best game of the
tournament
and i'm gonna leave the analysis of that
game to
uh to
tomorrow
and in the meantime i'm gonna
go and
get some rest
yeah i hope you guys enjoy
the analysis
you know i i i don't mean to bore people
to death
you know just trying to give you guys an
insight into what these what these games
looked like
and uh you know what was going through
my mind
[Music]